jazzy carolina es una mujer trans
colombiana que se vio obligada a huir de
su país aunque colombia es un estado que
posee protecciones amplias del colectivo
lgtb y ella sufrió discriminación
laboral y un rechazo familiar profundo
por su condición tenía mucho maltrato de
parte de mi jefe por mi condición y mi
identidad sexual
digamos que de mi familia tampoco tuve
el apoyo mi madre en algún momento
decidió sencillamente decirme
no estamos parados para esto a veces es
un poco fuerte para estas personas
muchas veces su mayor terror se
encuentra en su propia casa ya que hay
progenitores que deciden enviar a sus
hijos a terapias de reconversión sexual
estos pseudo tratamientos no tienen base
científica y por el contrario pueden
causar graves daños psíquicos y físicos
a las personas que son sometidos a ellos
sin embargo solamente son ilegales de
forma total en cuatro países y de forma
parcial en otros cinco en todo el mundo
pero la persecución hacia este colectivo
no se queda ahí en 12 países la
homosexualidad se castiga con la muerte
y en otros 57 con prisión la mayoría de
estas penas se concentran en áfrica y
medio oriente aunque también se dan en
américa y asia esto hace que las
solicitudes de asilo por la condición u
orientación sexual sean cada vez más
habituales algo que ha hecho que en
países como españa ya se hayan abierto
centros de acogida este centro lo que
les da es un poco esa libertad no de
sentirse de sentirse ellos mismos y
poder estar en un espacio seguro aunque
los países que protegen los derechos del
colectivo lgtb son cada vez más cada año
siguen asesinando
personas por su orientación y condición
sexual